[Music]
hunslet 800 Muska our parents think what
we're doing is really cool that sounds
sarcastic doesn't it now our parents
think it's great I can't say that
without sounding sarcastic but they
really do an exhibition that features
headphones and animal masks hands llanes
audio guides take young and old alike on
a journey into the world of art humor
instead of academic lectures that's
hands Yanez pitch making art accessible
these are beings that have somehow ended
up in a different world they're here to
break down fears of the unknown and
divert attention from a real context
which can seem dry and very formal our
masks are meant to destroy that context
context the stewart
the Hun's jana collective got its start
three years ago and went into business
this year now like most creative zen
berlin the artists are looking for
affordable studio space supporting and
promoting creative industry is on the
agenda at the Chancellery in Berlin it's
hosting a gathering of creative
newcomers and cultural pioneers 32
startups are here to meet politicians
including hands iana as well be put up
in we produce audio guides for
institutions and cultural events it's
all about the empowerment of women
through performance
yay for hooked I there's two constants
I'd say the crazy or something is the
more potential it has innovation and
entrepreneurship prove that there's no
such thing as crazy it's just a category
defined by normal people and progress
only happens if you don't accept norms
like that the Hun's yada collective
definitely don't accept norms being
labeled a woman's company gets on their
nerves when men go into business it's
called a company not a men's company
skip the bottom two tours there are
certain things that have seen as male
like establishing contacts and demanding
more money or talking about yourself but
these are things that we practice and
make a conscious effort to do even
though we aren't comfortable doing them
because we know they're important and we
have to learn how smiley and now they've
got a chance to show what they can do
600 applicants in Germany buy it for the
title of national creative and cultural
pioneers the prize a year of
individualized training courses
organized by Christophe Baucus missing
the catalytic single took care of people
who are actively creative and struggled
with precarious work are incredibly
qualified they have enormous potential
the first thing we have to do is teach
them to appreciate their value that
their work is really great that society
needs them the second thing is to get
them to stop working for nothing in one
session we spread money out on the desk
and tell them burn it because that's
what you're doing if you carry on
working the way you do now Germany's
creative capital Berlin offers many
sponsorship opportunities but compared
to the tech sector funding is thin
the Hun's jana partners try not to think
too much about their pro curious
livelihoods some are studying theatre
sciences others have part-time jobs to
keep them going their performances don't
generate enough income for six at least
not yet I just don't feel poor I
probably am objectively but I have a
really great life yet spragga zzz you're
probably asking yourself just how does
this performance increase capital hands
yadda is currently putting on 50
performance as a year and nowadays every
one of them is paid a lesson they've
learned as creative entrepreneurs
[Music]